man uses the spoken or written word to
express the meaning of what he wants to
convey his language is full of symbols
but he also often employs signs or
images that are not strictly descriptive
some are mere abbreviations or strings
of initials such as UN UNICEF or UNESCO
others are familiar trademarks the names
of patent medicines badges or insignia
although these are meaningless in
themselves they have acquired a
recognizable meaning through common
usage or deliberate intent such things
are not symbols they are signed and they
do no more than denote the object to
which they are attached what we call a
symbol is a term a name or even a
picture that may be familiar in daily
life yet that possesses specific
connotations in addition to its
conventional and obvious meaning it
implies something vague unknown or
hidden from us many Cretan monuments for
instance are marked with the design of
the double adds this is an object that
we know but we do not know it's symbolic
implications for another example take
the case of the Indian who after a visit
to England told his friends at home that
the English worship animals because he
had found eagles lions and oxen in old
churches he was not aware nor are many
Christians that these animals are
symbols of the evangelists and are
derived from the vision of Ezekiel and
that this in turn has an analogy to the
Egyptian Sun God Horus and his four sons
there are moreover such objects as the
wheel and the cross that are known all
over the world yet that have a symbolic
significance under certain conditions
precisely what they symbolize is still a
matter for controversial speculation
thus a word or an image is symbolic when
it implies something more than its
obvious and immediate meaning it has a
wider unconscious aspect that is never
precisely defined or fully explained nor
can one hope to define or explain it
as the mind explores the symbol it has
led to ideas that lie beyond the grasp
of reason the wheel may lead our
thoughts toward the concept of a divine
Sun but at this point reason must admit
its incompetence man is unable to define
a divine being when with all our
intellectual limitations we call
something divine
we have merely given it a name which may
be based on a Creed but never on factual
evidence because there are innumerable
things beyond the range of human
understanding we constantly use symbolic
terms to represent concepts that we
cannot define or fully comprehend this
is one reason why all religions employ
symbolic language or images but this
conscious use of symbols is only one
aspect of a psychological fact of great
importance man also produces symbols
unconsciously and spontaneously in the
form of dreams